the blind administration really can't
seem to get its messaging all sorted out
in different places on potential new
terror threats exp especially coming out
of afghanistan the contradictions over
the past few days raising red flags for
lawmakers white house correspondent
peter ducey has that part of the story
tonight
the story keeps changing are there al
qaeda
members and remnants in afghanistan yes
but two days earlier the president said
the opposite look let's put this thing
in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone
the confusion is concerning for critics
i'm absolutely concerned about it
clearly he's either seen out or just in
denial about what's going on
the national security adviser claims
there's nothing to see here are you
presenting the president with the full
picture or is he just misapplying the
intelligence when he makes these public
statements
the president was referring to al
qaeda's capability to attack the united
states which the intelligence community
tells us today
is not present in afghanistan
biden officials cite security risks as
the reason they won't explain how they
plan to evacuate americans who can't get
to the kabul airport i guess you can
play out different scenarios how we
could have withdrawn from afghanistan
but i'm pretty confident none of them
would be worse than what joe biden did
with thousands of americans stuck behind
taliban lines words matter and there's
one this white house doesn't want in
headlines about the afghanistan drawdown
does the president have a sense that
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not
there are no americans stranded is the
white house's official position on
what's happening in afghanistan i'm just
calling you out for saying that we are
stranding americans in afghanistan
and she argues none of these americans
who are sheltering in place hiding from
isis are stranded because they've been
getting texts and emails from the us
government president biden had two
on-camera events today one about covid
one celebrating the wnba champion
seattle storm not one word about
afghanistan right peter the text and
emails don't come with an armored
vehicle to get them to the airport
right and
at the same time a few minutes before
gensake spoke jake sullivan was up there
saying there is a serious threat from
isis at the airport so there are
americans who cannot go to the airport
but because it's too dangerous but
they're not stranded yeah
semantics there okay peter ducey live on
the north lawn peter thanks